the cowboys clearly need help as
promised here's more from
jerry jones owner and general manager of
the dallas cowboys when asked about
whether to what extent there's a
leadership issue with his franchise
does your team have a leadership void
we're in the offensive line
just just overall
but seriously seriously where do you
where would you have a leadership for is
it an experienced void is it a talent
void is it a leadership i'm not trying
to be cute here the answer is no
the answer is no i i'm asking
there's not a willing to shut up let me
answer
no
jerry when you go into the locker room
what i'm asking is do you see the
intangibles see that i gave you the i
gave you the answer
when i go into the locker room there's
no leadership void in my accent
okay now that's your answer
let's move on
now jerry did later apologize and he
said this there's an old adage don't
piss an old man off with a little money
he'll get you
i don't
i don't understand that i don't know
either but the guy's got a 250 million
dollar yacht yeah i don't know if he's
talking about himself
well he's not a little money i mean he's
a lot of money
yeah yeah uh which is even more reason
not to piss the old man off because you
don't want to be written out of the will
yeah that's absolutely right sean and rj
from 105.3 the fan have jeopardized
their inheritance by pissing off an old
man with a lot of money
and they've also jeopardized their
ability to ever go for a ride on his 250
million dollar boat look there's clearly
an issue and setting aside the question
of whether or not jerry jones should
even be walking into the locker room
anyway given that he's 78 and there's a
pandemic happening
i don't know who the leaders are right
now who are the leaders where were the
leaders i don't want to go back and
rehash the absence of a reaction to andy
dalton getting blown up by john bostic
because i think we have identified the
combination of a bunch of guys who
weren't even supposed to be on the field
wondering what the hell to do and
everybody's so freaked out by the fact
that he was injured that it's not your
normal go push and shove and retaliate
type of a thing but still look around
where are the leaders who are the
leaders on this team chris with dak
prescott gone and with ezekiel elliott
caught in this vortex of self-doubt yeah
no i i mean i think it's a very fair
question right now i do i mean again the
reaction yes
you know overblown certainly the way the
game has the games have looked
you know as far as them letting up all
these points the mistakes
you know some blown
uh situations as far as managing them
from mike mccarthy so when you have
those issues people start to question it
i mean that that's that's really all
there is to it you know and and and
again i understand it's the world we
live in because the results of the
cowboys aren't very good so people start
to do that but yeah i mean they've
they've lost a lot of their leaders and
dak prescott certainly being one of the
big ones but then hey the guys on the
offensive line i mean that was always a
big part of their football team so
tyrone smith zach martin i know he was
you know been banged up but lyle collins
that group of guys travis fredericks who
decides to you know get rid of that get
out of football all those there's been
some turnover there as far as those type
of guys that maybe would have been
pissed off and set up a new attitude the
last few weeks with the way they played
or what happened to andy dalton and all
those issues so no i don't necessarily
look at it as like a lack of leadership
i look at it as a a team who's in
turmoil they have issues and some of
their best leaders are just not on the
field for them to kind of steer the ship
in the right direction
and the coach isn't getting it done from
a leadership style point plain and
simple and jerry jones was also asked
yesterday about his head coach mike
mccarthy because it's been so much
speculation could it be won and done
could it be fired during the year look
jerry jones will completely and totally
and unconditionally support you until
the moment he no longer does so you
can't rule out anything because all he
has to do is roll out of bed the wrong
way and he feels differently about
somebody like that here he is yesterday
talking about his first year head coach
without a question the reasons that mike
mccarthy is the coach
is because he's been through it and he's
had
tough times and he's had disappointing
times certainly we couldn't have
anticipated uh being at this stage with
our team this year but if i were going
to hire a head coach
that we're going to be at the stage this
year and work through this for the
betterment of what's in store for us for
the rest of year and for what's for us
in the future i got my man
look i i think mike mccarthy's the head
coach of the cowboys for one very simple
reason he repeatedly kicked their butts
with a lesser team in green bay yeah and
that's what that's the selling point and
and if you're jerry jones the guy who
built the team that consistently lost to
the packers when mike mccarthy was the
coach you've got a pretty good audience
a pretty willing audience that is going
to say yeah you know you're right we
were better than the packers and you
brought an inferior team in here and
beat us but
look maybe it's the lack of an off
season program maybe it's all the
struggles and issues the pandemic i
don't know i don't want to prejudge mike
mccarthy does have a super bowl win on
his resume and there aren't many
individuals who can say that right head
coaches
but still something's not something's
not right and and i feel like
i can't put my finger on it i feel like
it's so much you you need you need all
10 fingers and then some
to put on what the issues are with the
cowboys and it just doesn't seem like
they they've begun to figure out chris
how to come up with answers no they have
well and it's hard because you can't see
the results on the field so that's it's
going to continue to make it look like
there's no answers because there's
nothing to look at on the football field
to go oh hey yeah you know the attitude
it did seem you know the media the
attitude did seem better in the locker
room or on the practice field that we
got to see this week you know you'd be
able to justify those things with
winning a football game that's not going
to happen i mean it's not i mean they're
they're in trouble here who knows losing
how many football games as we go mike
mccarthy has been through it all he
dealt with a lot of controversy how to
deal with you know
brett favre to aaron rodgers stuff in
green bay he really had to deal with it
all all the aaron rodgers drama towards
the end all those things yes
i mean so he is a battle-tested football
coach but you know
lack of detail
lack of you know head coaching
management of the football games in
certain situations where issues you know
turnovers of course the way the defense
is looked which doesn't necessarily
should be blamed on mike mccarthy you
know that's the other issue too that we
always got to remember when you talk
about the dallas cowboys
yeah the jones family gets involved in
some of the coaching decisions some of
the coaching staff all those things so
yeah there's the mike nolan defensive
disconnect with the the players and do
they fit the scheme and that's not
necessarily mike mccarthy's fault in a
lot of ways so there's issues throughout
the organization right now let alone
they're a beat up football team and i
think jerry will be smart enough to stay
the course here and not panic and
realize that wow we've had a lot of bad
luck this year we've had some things go
against us no off season as well like
you mentioned
and
i'm gonna stay the course with the guy
that i believe is the right guy and i
would be shocked if he fired him or
or abandoned shipped after one year
let's have some fun yeah you'd like to
have some fun i want to have some fun go
ahead and put the bingo thing up there
because we're going through the rest of
the schedule for the cowboys and if it's
acceptable to do it in april or may when
the schedule comes out and there are
months to go before you even begin the
season yeah i think it's perfectly
acceptable right to do it in late
october when there are games left let's
go game by game you tell me gut reaction
winner loss for the cowboys rest of the
way are you ready yeah i'm ready at
eagles sunday night football nbc win or
a loss loss i'm picking eagles all day
long
steelers the following weekend
[Laughter]
lost okay so yeah all right bye week
winner loss and buy one only they could
probably find a way to lose in the bye
week knowing that
all right
at the vikings coming out of the by the
weekend before the thanksgiving game i
mean that's a coin flip type game and i
would go i i think there's more
you know can are the cowboys be able to
stop dalvin cook in that running game
and all that i i think not
so i'm going with a loss as well all
right at home
thanksgiving afternoon ron rivera and
the washington football team keep in
mind ron rivera took the panthers in
there on a thanksgiving a few years ago
and kicked the crap out of the cowboys
that'll win or lost
man i i'll say the cowboys somehow find
some thanksgiving magic and figure out a
window a way to win one that game right
there
one week later thursday night football
at the ravens well come on let me that's
just laughable steelers game
at the bengals the next week
that's another coin flip i mean that is
a true coin flip football game where
the way it look i would go with the
bangles right now i would with the way
joe burrow and that offense are moving
see ya sorry dallas you're gonna lose
last two games eagles at home followed
by at the giants well you skipped the
49ers too i skipped the 49ers all right
there's another lost forget it yeah
they're going to lose them again and
then the giants will come down to like
you know i don't know what team you know
what team messes it up will evan ingram
drop a pass to ice the game will daniel
jones trip and fall
i don't know but the cowboys do
something stupid that they do every game
who knows so yeah there we go pete
as pete points out the giants will lose
that game and squander the number one
overall pick in the process look that's
four and twelve that i see four and
twelve yeah i do too i mean at the very
four and twelve
and
we were being nice and giving them a win
to washington who just beat the crap out
of them
and
who else the giants we gave them that
you're right i mean that's nice i mean
they could have lost to the giants the
first time around so
i mean again they might not win again i
wouldn't be shocked i really wouldn't be
here's how bad they are right now
they're playing an eagles team that is
two four and one
and they're seven and a half point
underdogs yeah for sunday night football
on on nbc
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports